in the last video we talk about the
first 200 years of rome being an
official empire starting with
augustus and 27 bce going all the way to
marcus aurelius and that time period is
referred to as pax romana roman peace
it's a relatively stable relatively uh a
peaceful time for rome now all of that
is relative if you're one of the tribes
that are still fighting with the roman
legions if you're one of the roughly
one-fourth to one-third of the
population that is a slave you might not
view this as such a good time but things
only get worse after the death of marcus
aurelius who's viewed as the last of the
five good emperors so to speak his son
commodus takes over and commodus is the
beginning of a succession of emperors
who are less and less competent who are
the empire becomes more and more corrupt
less and less stable and things really
come to a head and start to decelerate
even further or i guess accelerate
downward even further in
235 ce
when the emperor severus alexander is
assassinated and this throws the empire
into a 50-year crisis called the third
century crisis
because it happened in the third century
and over this 50 years there's 26
claimants to emperor the empire is
temporarily split into three different
states there's attacks from the east
from the sassanids the sasanian empire
they're the successors to the parthians
you have attacks across the rhine and
the danube from germanic tribes all of
that makes this a very unstable period
for rome
now the third century crisis is
considered to end in 284 with the
ascension of diocletian
and diocletian is viewed as a somewhat
or a reasonably strong emperor he's
known as the last emperor that really
persecuted the christians because
they didn't follow the roman religion
they did not they did not worship the
emperor as a god
but he's also or maybe he's most famous
for splitting the empire he decides that
probably one of the main causes of the
third century crisis is that the empire
has gotten too vast it has too many
borders it's hard for one emperor to
administer the whole thing so he splits
it into east and west from an
administrative point of view he doesn't
they don't become separate empires but
he decides that he is going to rule from
the east and that he will have a
co-emperor who rules from the west and
not only does he set that up but he had
he sets up a what's called a tetrarchy
beyond himself and his co-emperor they
have a sec they each have a second in
command that if any one of them were to
die or would have to retire somehow that
that second in command could take over
and once again this is to address some
of the issues of the third century
crisis where the the wars for succession
and this isn't just during the third
century crisis we've seen in multiple
videos rome is famous even during the
pax romana for these really ugly
succession battles but as we'll see the
splitting of the empire into east and
west even though it started as an
administrative thing over time it's
going to become a real split and they're
going to turn into two different empires
now after diocletian you have another
significant emperor you have constantine
and constantine
is known for
many things
maybe most famously he embraced
christianity as opposed to diocletian
who who persecuted christians you have
the the council of nicaea and the nicean
code where there's now a uniform
church doctrine around christianity he
has the edict of milan which makes
christianity
illegal under roman rule maybe most
famously on his deathbed he gets
baptized he becomes the first christian
emperor he also moves the capital to
officially moves the capital of the
entire empire of the entire empire to
what at the time was
byzantium but then he renames it to
constantinople named after
him
now he was still it was still one
unified empire empire even diocletian
who co-ruled with the co-emperor he had
veto power over the emperor to the west
now as we get further into the 4th
century here and especially into the 5th
century we'll see that the empire
further and further fragments and gets
diluted and really just breaks down
one major
factor in that breakdown is in that
fourth century in the fourth and fifth
centuries you have a group called the
huns coming in
from central asia coming in from
northern europe right over here and they
are fierce
nomadic conquerors and they're so fierce
that they start pushing more of the
dying the germanic tribes across the
rhine and the danube and a lot of these
germanic tribes at first even though
they their history has been fighting the
romans a lot of them try to seek refuge
in the roman empire and they're given
refuge in the roman empire but while
they have that refuge they're treated
very very very badly and all of that
comes to a head in the like i should say
the the last quarter of the fourth
century with the gothic wars and the
gothic wars really have a decisive
battle at adrian opal originally
hadrianopolis named after the emperor
hadrian and adrianopolis at adrian opal
the gothic tribes in particular and when
we say gothic we're really talking about
germanic tribes and this one in
particular as you can see from this
legend right over here this is the
visigots or western gods they're able to
decisively defeat the eastern roman
emperor valance he's actually killed at
adrian opal and then the visigoths just
continue to hang out here in in the
roman empire and they continue to move
forward in 410 they're able to actually
sack rome and they eventually settle in
the iberian peninsula and in southern
gaul
now after the battle of adrian opal you
have another significant emperor
theodosius because what you'll see is is
that diocletian persecuted christians
constantine now embraces christianity he
becomes a christian he says christianity
is legal theodosius now right as we are
about to enter into the fifth century he
makes christianity the official religion
of the roman empire so in roughly 100
years the roman empire went from
persecuting christians to making it the
official the official religion and
actually going the other way starting to
persecute some of the pre
christian
religions or rituals
the other thing that happens as we enter
into the 5th century now
the as we go into the fifth century
you have the the capital of the western
empire is moved from rome to ravenna
with the idea that you the the emperors
see all of these germanic tribes they
feel threatened by them that ravenna is
easier to defend it's surrounded by kind
of marshy swampy area the other thing of
of note about theodacio theodosius and
as we move into this this this really
the last century of the western roman
empire is theodosius was the last roman
emperor to rule all of rome after that
the east and west are going to be ruled
essentially independently they're
essentially going to be separate empires
but then as we get into the fifth
century we already talked about the
visigoths sacking rome
then in 455 you have the vandals which
is another germanic tribe that was
similarly originally pushed out by the
huns you see them in blue right over
here they make it down the iberian
peninsula into north africa they
eventually get to to carthage and they
become a little bit of a naval power and
they eventually are able to in 455
sack rome as well so rome is is really
uh taking a hit multiple times and then
finally the the end of the roman empire
or the western roman empire what that
most historians consider the end of the
roman empire is when the germanic
ruler general odo acer or odo aker
depending on how you pronounce it is
able to oust the emperor in ravana and
ravenna and so then you have the
official and just to be clear this isn't
this is
wrong let me write roman
empire
and so odo acer is able to essentially
end the western empire as we know it and
after that the western empire becomes
more and more fragmented into these
kingdoms that are ruled by essentially
germanic kings and that we are now
entering into the middle ages now the
big question that historians have a lot
of fun thinking about is why did all of
this happen why did the roman empire
fall and before we even talk about why
it fell it's we should give them a
little bit of credit even in this video
where i talk about the fall of the roman
empire i'm covering 300 years of history
and if you start with the founding of
the republic until odo acer takes over
ravenna outs the emperor we're talking a
thousand years most civilizations most
empires don't last anywhere
near that long so to some degree there's
it's it's surprising that it lasted so
long but in terms of the causes of its
decline
we've talked about several of them in
this video the empire got divided the
east and west stopped viewing themselves
so much as the same empire trade
sometimes broke down they didn't support
each other militarily the eastern empire
was generally stronger so it allowed
invading tribes to focus on the weak
point in the west some historians would
say that the roman empire stopped
expanding and it needed that expansion
in order to keep getting more land and
more slaves that really drove its
economy
one major factor probably was the huns
that caused this great migration in the
fourth and fifth centuries that caused
the germanic tribes to cross the rhine
and cross the danube and become either
or either settle as part of the roman
empire or threaten the roman empire
another theory and all of these are
probably contributors is that as the
germanic tribe settled they actually
became more and more
part of the roman military and some of
them
were
officially part of the military some of
them were mercenaries soldiers for
fortune paid soldiers and so you can
imagine their allegiance to rome was not
as strong
some folks say christianity may have
been a factor that the empire might have
lasted especially when people were doing
what their traditional
rights rituals they worshipped an
emperor but now christianity wasn't
about worshiping an emperor anymore a
lot of people think it's corruption
instability and we've talked a little
bit about that it could have been
invasions not just from the germanic
tribes and the huns but also the
sassanids on the east so i'll leave you
there and
to think about what was the cause or
maybe what allowed the roman empire to
survive for so long